Okay so we just have one lesson
that covers law ethics and
privacy so we not talking about
any of these in great detail.
As I said, I only talked about two of
the laws, I didn't get into privacy.
But we do want to very briefly talk
about some of ethics related to.
Online activities.
So what's the difference
between laws and ethics?
We know that ethics have
to do with sort of,
an individual's sense of
what is right and wrong.
On the other hand, laws are sort of
societal, we as a society decide state,
local, or federal, whatever it
is laws that say what is wrong.
If you did that, you would have
certain kind of sanctions.
Laws may not cover certain things,
but your sense of right and
wrong might say well I
should not be doing this.
And we talking about that.
In the context of what we do online or
what we do in cyber space.
Before we sort of go further,
it's worthwhile pointing out
that when it comes to your ethical
sort of your sense of right and wrong,
of course there is no external
arbiter or enforcement agency like
law where we have police and
the courts and things like that.
So what's sort of the example of an
ethical code that you could think about?
So what happens if you
discover a vulnerability in
a commercial product that's used
by lots and lots of people?
What is ethical disclosure
of this vulnerability?
So here is the idea and the dilemma.
If you disclose it,
it's disclosed to the bad guys.
The bad guys can then exploit it.
And then can go and
attack the system in which you have
discovered a vulnerability, okay?
So that said, maybe disclosing
it is not a great thing,
the other way to think about this
is that if you don't disclose it
that doesn't mean that the bad guys
actually you want to find out about it.
And if you don't disclose it, then,
there's no pressure on the vendor who
actually produced this
commercial system or
product to actually do
something about it, okay?
So, by disclosing,
you sort of fix in with problem or
vulnerability we have,
hopefully in a timely fashion.
But at the same time, you're also making
this information available to bad guys.
So that's where do you draw the line?
What's the ethical thing to do here?
So of course, we have our personal
notion of right and wrong.
So, it could be sort of your
personal thing or it could be a code
of conduct defined by some professional
society that you may be a member of.
So ACM or I triple E,
or even Georgia Tech.
So ethical standards are, in a court
of conduct, doing the right thing.
Knowing what's right and
what is wrong of course, laws and
ethics go together to help
us understand what is that
we can do without doing anything
illegal or doing anything wrong versus
what is that should not be done
because that's the wrong thing to do.